good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy thursday we are
joined for a little afternoon toast
by my own mistake we will get into it
please welcome today's co-host sophia
franklin sofia with an f woo
hi everyone i'm back yes back from the
dead let's let's talk about why we're
here so late and let's talk about how
it's 100 my fault
well yeah so you take it over i mean let
me just say i look like a wet dog i'm
soaking wet yeah we both got stuck in
the same paddy's day parade it was
probably one of the lowest moments of my
life trying to get to work today and not
being able to cross any streets and
being stuck in the rain and wanting to
literally die having to beg a police
officer to just please can i cross the
street to get to my office and then tell
you to [ __ ] off
it's like i never realized how
privileged i am to be able to just cross
the street it's humbling to be told like
no ma'am you have to go all the way
around yes in the rain yes and there was
a line claudia did i skip the line 100
there was a line to cross the street
it's just i i can't i just i can't so i
texted sophia like we love you when you
come back on the toast while jackie's on
maternity leave she was so gracious she
said yes of course no problem and so i
was like great
10 30. in my mind that's what i said
and then i wake up this morning
bright-eyed bushy-tailed ready to see my
favorite co-host and i saw i have a
message from you at one in the morning
last night you're like did you say 1 30
because your google calendar says 10 30
but you told me 1 30. i'm like oh sophia
being crazy again
i was about to blame you and then i
scroll up and i realize i typed to you
130 because i'm a [ __ ] who doesn't know
how to type and i never read and i just
like send things off and then i live
with go on with my life right so we are
here at 1 30 because i don't know how to
type you have been very flexible and i
really appreciate and i apologize the
funny thing is is when claudia texted me
you actually did the same typo again oh
oh yeah like that's how [ __ ] up it is
is then again you said no it's for 1 30.
yes and then he said no asterisk
asterisk whatever 10 30. yeah no you're
right i did make the same mistake twice
so it's 1 30. sophia got here we're so
grateful thank you so much again 100 my
fault
well
i mean
not i'm going to blame it on the parade
on this ain't patty's day parade 100
like it's not on you it's on them and it
never is on me that's never ever ever
ever that's the lesson so sophia's
joining me today we're going to do the
whole show with sophia which is so
exciting because your last stint on this
show was so well received and like look
at us press girlies making press
everywhere we go does that give you
anxiety when you end up end up in the
press
um did we end up in the press or
we were in literally like all these
magazines wait are you [ __ ] with me
i'm just serious claudia i don't live on
planet earth you don't have like a
google alert i live in no uh
no
you should it's so exciting
really because we were on page six we
were in like us magazine yeah oh my what
bits of our interview were picked up
because like we were making news wait
also i'm about to fire my entire team
and like pr and like where the hell are
they no nobody sent it to you like we
were literally stars okay well i would
love to see those articles if i had
google alerts on for my name the anxiety
i would wake up with every morning right
you like it you're kind of sick like
that claudia you kind of like it you
want to know why because like if
something bad is happening like i need
to know about it like i'm i live in
crisis mode permanently oh really i'm
from denial it's from my trauma okay i'm
denial mode that's how you cope i'm like
whatever if i don't see it it doesn't
exist i guess it's fair you know but i
see everything i can tell i see that so
much of your work is on your phone do
you then when you're done working like
are you the type of person who's on
their phone a lot or no
a constantly yeah yeah for sure we're
being taunted by those bagpipes do you
hear them i like or is it or is it like
a trauma trigger like i'm not there
aren't bagpipes no there are bagpipes i
just i do they would like go in circles
like this
around this building just like 50 times
in a row i'm gonna be trying to sleep
tonight and i'm gonna hear like dude
oh my god guys and it's it's it i'm
we're not saying the parade is
necessarily no disrespect to the irish
we're so proud of your heritage but like
can you [ __ ] off
it's [ __ ] raining also it's a
thursday also it's the middle of the day
the irish are obviously they can't be
stopped like even the rain won't stop
their pride no and directly in the
center of midtown it's insane why don't
we go just around the city the west side
highway you know what there's probably a
reason that we don't understand claudia
so you are going to join me here today
to talk about all things in pop culture
are you like a big pop culture girly do
you keep up i not huge but i do like to
like divulge here and there are you a
well it's not divulged what the [ __ ] is
there no
like what is the word
divulge like kind of works too like if
you don't know anything i would have
been like i know [ __ ] okay indulge
and so this week and actually like the
last month has been like so kardashian
heavy obviously because i like the kim
kanye drama now there's more stuff
coming out
um before we get into this i just need
to know like where as a person because
last time we talked about pop culture
housewives like we were really extremely
divided i'm curious where you landed on
the kardashians like are you a big
kardashian girly i
love them i don't watch them religiously
but i actually really really love them i
think they're genuinely funny me too
watching the show people try to [ __ ] on
them so much i think they're hilarious
same and you're not one of those people
who just like hates them to hate no and
they remind me of kind of my family even
though i don't have one sister but just
i see the similarity but just my mom and
my aunts and you know we're kind of like
that and inappropriate are you and yours
is very similar that's why we've always
loved them like the sister dynamics
totally family first you love that yes
okay good i love them i just want to
make sure before we you know
set off that we're on the right foot yes
okay well i think that we should jump in
because i'm so excited to hear what
sofia has to say about all the juicy
tidbits and
let's do it let's dive into the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
nailed it okay today's episode is
brought to you by fuzzy if you have a
pet then they're part of your family and
fuzzy knows there's nothing that
compares to coming home to a wiggle of a
butt or waking up to soft purrs and we
want to keep our pets healthy and make
them as happy as they make us fuzzy is a
telehealth service for pet parents that
offers 24 7 access to personalized pet
care from veterinary veterinary
professionals i happen to use fuzzy i've
used it before they were a sponsor my
vet dr lisa love you shout out
recommended them it's so nice to have
all that access on your fingertips like
if you've ever woken up in the middle of
the night and your dog ate your vaseline
and you didn't know what to do having
the app on your phone is just brings
such peace of mind
from everyday questions to middle of the
night emergencies fuzzy has the answers
every pet parent needs through live chat
and virtual vet consultations available
to you 24 hours a day seven days a week
fuzzy can answer your pet questions big
and small right now fuzzy's offering our
listeners a free seven-day trial
membership go to yourfuzzy.com toast
today to sign up that's a free 7-day
trial and access to our exclusive member
discounts on pet meds supplements food
and more at
y-o-u-r-fuzzy dot com slash toast that's
your fuzzy your f-u-z-z-y dot com
toast excuse me for your free trial of
fuzzy with access to 24 7 personalized
care
and today's episode is also brought to
you by our friends at manscaped the
global leader in below the waste hygiene
they're turning men's shower dreams into
their favorite routine with the all-new
ultra premium collection this all-in-one
hygiene skin and hair bundle is designed
to upgrade the everyday man's shower
routine from head to toe
his skin his hair nails balls everything
deserve it save big by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with the code toast ben is a
big manscaped user ben doesn't even have
like a routine so just to buy the ultra
premium collection just everything he
needs in one bin it's not like that
complicated because men aren't that
smart it has everything they need ben
loves it he's been using it for a while
the elite trimmer is designed to trim
hair on loose skin like testicles keep
him safe in the battlefield with his
proprietary skin safe technology the new
bundle will change his life and you know
what it'll change yours as well get 20
off and free shipping with
codetoast.manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with
codetoast.manscape.com
let's get the man in your life nice and
clean with the new manscaped shower
trimmer
okay so let's dive into the stories the
first story is like changing the world
as of yesterday um kim kardashian is
going on ellen and some of the clips
came out before she her appearance
actually airs and she let us know that
pete davidson got kim kardashian's name
branded on his chest as a scar
so actually you don't even need to read
the article i literally know everything
so
all these texts were released between
between pete and kanye and pete had sent
a picture of himself to kanye and he's
like i'm in your wife's bed haha and so
many people noticed that he had a tattoo
on his chest of kim if people were
freaking out like a tattoo oh my god
such a big deal then kim went on ellen
and actually said it's not a tattoo it's
branded like it's a scar
i
am at a loss for [ __ ] words yeah how
does that go down does someone carve it
into a skin is it like what you do to
cows it's what you do
it's like a really hot metal rod that i
guess the metal spells out kim so that's
basic he's basically like i can never
cover this [ __ ] up ever ever right
unless i turn it into like a square
that's the point it's like you know
tattoos technically they're permanent
but you know he's had a million
girlfriends ariana grande got a tattoo
of him she had it removed technically
tattoos are permanent but for
celebrities they seem to be like kind of
indispensable right so this is like you
can't ever unbrand yourself like there's
no there are tattoo removals there's not
brand run removals like no
no no it's for life
i
think that's the dumbest [ __ ] i've ever
heard to be completely honest i mean
would you want um ben doing that for you
i would
i would but that doesn't mean i think
it's a good idea uh-huh like i like the
idea of him having something
permanent on himself i do
but this is like psychotic especially
you know they met in october let's get
some perspective that's the thing and
where is it on his chest like very
prominent right here right there like
where my left breast is
okay where your heart is oh
wait let me think he was laying in the
bed
it might have been his right but the
iphone flips it okay so that would make
sense regardless i i think that's so
stupid i like them as a couple but
like like carving into your skin or
burning it or whatever come on it's
animalistic like we don't need to do we
don't but what do you think about them
as a couple are you attracted to pete
davidson i am not
i
me i saw him
a month ago or maybe less than that i
was invited to this exclusive private um
dave chappelle you were
and can you talk about it or not no yeah
it was
in the most random spot i don't know
where it was it was in the basement of
some restaurant in new york yes in new
york it wasn't like you couldn't buy
tickets or anything right
um dave chappelle performed and pete
davidson performed
i spent the entire time looking for kim
she was not there i was very upset
pete
uh
i i didn't find him attractive i also
just want to say
i don't know if stand-up is his strong
suit what i know
no and that's and that's coming from me
maybe he was just having an off day i
also saw him live on snl
he just he doesn't seem that well i mean
maybe he was going through something
that's an extremely hot take yes yeah
what was he said about was it about kim
um
i think he did make one joke about kim
he was really just opening for dave
right
uh but yes i saw him for a split second
not attracted to him
or his comedy
not in that way not in that setting i'm
shook by this news yeah you've never
thought that i mean do you like his
stand-up i've never seen it but i did
see his um netflix special which was
like 40 minutes it was really short it
felt very low energy but it did feel
like all this stuff with ariana grande
had just happened and she was out
writing songs and talking about him and
he had never really said anything about
it so most of the special was i think
him just addressing this major it was
like his first real before that he was
like a popular comedian not like a major
a-list celebrity so i think he had to
just like finally address it and there
were some really good jokes in it it was
good it was fine it wasn't like life
changing like some of these stuff but it
it was good it was fine right and i mean
when i saw him he's being you know
harassed by kanye west every single day
so i'm sure his mental head space i mean
whatever whatever it was i wasn't that
impressed he's a thousand times better
than i would ever be so i don't know why
the [ __ ] i'm talking but
yes i saw him a few weeks ago not
attracted to jackie loves to quote the
great jerry seinfeld comedy is more per
no yeah
comedy is more personal than food like
everyone has their really own tastes i
love that tape and then jackie applies
that like phrase to everything like
podcasting is more personal than comedy
i'm using that any time like something
doesn't land
like someone says my episode is [ __ ]
like every single time no it's actually
like a really good piece of advice
okay so i i think the branding is
definitely a unique choice
i try not to be a judgmental person
that's like one of my goals in my new
life like i really try to just like let
people live their lives and even though
it's definitely not something i would
ever do right um i'm i'm happy for them
there is something there's a very sexy
element to it i have been talking to
this guy
recently
and we just like
hot and heavy just right off the bat he
already has tattoos he said he wanted to
get sophia tattooed
um across his thigh so i can like see it
while we're like you know
making love
and it's a
i'm scared and i told him not to but at
the same time i'm like please go do it
that's a turn on that is so sexy i want
you you like are that girl though like i
could just see you being that girl who
makes like millions of men get tattoos
of your name on them and they're going
to spell it as f-o-f-i-a
no it's actually f-o-p-h i a
is how my therapist [ __ ] wrote to me
one time oh my god that is beyond funny
what's the craziest do you have any
tattoos no are you against them or um
i think
on men okay i'm gonna get in a lot of
[ __ ] i think on men they're sexy i do
think that there can be a trashy element
like depending on the tattoo um i like
them a little bit less on women again i
think there are some that i find
attractive and think are hot
i don't know for me
i wouldn't necessarily want to be
walking down the aisle in a wedding
dress and you know you have a tattoo
showing i think that's the sentiment a
lot of people share yeah i've never had
to think about getting one because it's
against my religion oh okay it is like
you can't you can't be buried in a
jewish senator
jewish yeah well it's for all jews like
you really can't be buried in a jewish
cemetery if you have a tattoo okay well
i'm jewish so i guess i absolutely you
are yeah did you cover this last time or
no i don't think so tell me oh my god
life-changing happy purim tell me a
happy prayer to all of our jewish
listeners tell me about your jewish
heritage i'm
it's bizarre it's very very bizarre so
my i'm jewish on my mom's side which is
how it's passed down it's a matrimonial
thing if your mom is jewish and your dad
is not you are technically jewish if
your dad is jewish and your mom is not
you are technically yes okay so there
you go
um my grandma was born in argentina but
she migra migrated there from ukraine
raised very very jewish
moved from argentina there's a lot of
jewish people in argentina
um moved from argentina to utah where
i'm from similar just a little swerve i
think i was one of five jewish people
there oh my god of course um
but she
then met my grandpa and decided to
convert to
mormonism oh no way a little flip on
that were you raised mormon
a little bit yeah really yes and it
[ __ ] with my psyche and that's why i
talk about sex and i'm you know kind of
crazy i think i'm not gonna lie but
um i also went to private catholic
school
so i'm just [ __ ] up in all all
different ways but when did you stop
practicing mormonism
um
i never really did
but that doesn't change the fact that my
mom is you know there's like a lot of
people feel very interested
but i think you know for my grandma
she's
she practices mormonism but she
considers herself jewish and she's still
you know she's still we celebrate
hanukkah and all of those things i love
that yeah
you're all queen yeah you're ethnically
jewish right so you can convert but your
blood is still jewish exactly oh my god
i'm learning so much about
ashkenazi
me too you should come over for shabbat
we i really really want to i've only
been to a few and i would love that and
if you do it right they could be so fun
like you just get lit and eat everything
inside okay are you gonna invite me to
the next i would love to i'm so excited
oh my god i cannot believe sofia is a
jewish queen that just like changes
everything um okay so you don't have any
tattoos that was that's where we started
zero maybe that's where it came from but
you talking about utah reminds me you
just moved to new york
uh i've been here for a week how is it
um
incredible
horrifying amazing terrifying
all over the place it feels really
really good to be back i forgot just
how
much of a [ __ ] show it is i mean i had a
car
right i didn't have to get a certificate
of insurance and be approved by 27
people to get a couch to get a couch
yeah you know just those types of course
and plus i have no furniture in my
apartment so i'm really living in
squalor the
first few weeks now actually because of
cobait and furniture delays are like
months the first few weeks slash months
of in a new apartment where like you're
on the mattress on the floor you don't
have blinds is so dark literally very
yeah very dark horrible well on top of
your hair well thank you so much by the
way i'm having the best time ever i'm
never leaving i love it so much but
also you have to like realize i just
went from living with my family and my
boyfriend
in the same house
to living completely alone so two years
with mom brother boyfriend a million
people roommates before that and now
living alone do you like living alone
i love it i have realized there are
certain
i find myself doing certain things like
oh it's really silent in here i guess i
should turn the tv on
for background yeah like there's little
things like that and it's like wait it
feels a little bit empty i think i need
to call someone like right now
you know [ __ ] like that but are you the
type of person who likes being alone
like i am terrified of the dark i hate
i've never lived by myself like i i
think it takes a really secure and
independent type of person to be able to
like flourish on their own well i'm not
bit yeah because i do really really like
it you do especially i guess coming from
like a little bit of chaos yeah there
there's so many people in your house
before yes also though i have spent the
last week like from the day i touched
down till probably
yesterday just going out
drinking partying that was gonna be the
next question yeah i've been going out a
lot where are sophia's favorite places
to go out in new york
well let's see where did i go i've been
to socialista quite a bit i went to zero
bond
i wanted to talk to you about that
because i know you're a member yes um
gorgeous inside stunning good food great
vibes good food yeah okay can you go
there during the day or no yeah uh i've
never been but you can i think it's like
because it's a i think people like to
work there have meetings that's what i'm
saying i kind of want to get a
membership you can definitely like work
from there i'm a huge fan of xerobond i
hope they open more um locations in
different cities yeah gorgeous inside
uh where else have i been just really
all over the place people had friends in
new york
um yes i do
not i feel like my friends are spread
out throughout the us and a lot of
continental queen yes thank you so much
but they pop in and out i wouldn't say
i have so many [ __ ] friends here but
like i have a good core group that
matters and i'm meeting people just
rapidly and it's just great for the
podcast like you're building your
business so many people come in and out
of new york so many people live here who
have podcasts must be easier for you now
to have in-person guests and stuff
that was i mean that was one of the
biggest reasons that i was like i need
to get out of utah and go to new york
because what type of collaborations am i
doing in utah the real housewives of
salt lake city rachel parsons i was just
gonna say rache parcell do you stand
rachel parcell we're obsessed with her
here yes
i do
what no no nope no i don't want to hear
anything bad i'm obsessed no
i am obsessed with her i was gonna just
spill a little tea that's not even bad
about her but then i was like that's
teen i don't want to be that [ __ ] but
you know i usually want to hear tea but
not for no her style is amazing her home
i um was on the same cheerleading team
as her shut up i used to stare at her
all day long and be like um she's a
goddess for those who don't know rach
parcell is a
really really big um
instagram fashion icon queen she's like
one of those she's the original and the
biggest like mormon blogger her content
is so premium her kids are so cute she
has her own line of clothing i love her
i i do love her too have you seen her
clothes in nordstrom it's amazing i have
every time she wears her sunday best to
church i'm like gotta go to church yeah
right i never bought anything because i
would never wear a dress like that in my
life unless i was going to church and
i'm jewish and like i barely go to
synagogue right so exactly what there
will be an event in my life one day that
requires a rach parcell dress and i will
be purchasing it okay and you need to
tell me and i want to see it but i mean
that's what i'm saying if i were to do a
collab in utah it would be with a mommy
blogger
or you know a real housewife yeah and
that's not really my brand no no it's
more my brand actually it really isn't
uh it really is so um
i i have to i had to move back here yeah
no i'm so glad you're here right you've
got a friend in me oh my god what wait
what did you say and you've got a friend
in me oh my god i thought you said you
unfriended me no no you better be like
what are you better talking about okay
um okay that was quite a tangent but
back to the kardashians the second story
is about kanye west he's been suspended
from instagram for 24 hours after a
trevor noah attack man i'm so like well
read on these stories today i don't even
need to read the articles let me tell
you what happened trevor noah did this
actually quite beautiful segment on his
show
um talking about how he grew up in a in
an abusive home from the ages of nine to
16. and what a lot of people and it's
actually very similar to something i
said on the show what a lot of people
aren't talking about with this kim and
kanye stuff it's like what kanye is
doing it's like yeah we're all consuming
it it's like funny ha ha but it's abuse
and it's harassment and it's not letting
an ex of yours go and just berating them
and this happens to millions of women
who don't have the security and the
money that kim kardashian has and that's
why when what people are always like to
abusive women like why didn't you leave
it's like well look what happens when
someone does leave and so
he really said a lot of very profound
things in defense of kim and just like
defending women and kanye obviously
didn't like it and he posted you know a
bunch of [ __ ] on his instagram and one
of the things he posted was very
inappropriate in the caption i think it
was four or five times he referred to
trevor noah as a racial slur um the k
word
which wow was beyond and
uh metta which is a company that owns
instagram and facebook
disabled his account for 24 hours he's
unable to comment send messages or post
for 24 hours and they also said that if
kanye continues to violate the policies
the company will take additional steps
so i just feel like this is instagram
out here doing the bare minimum like the
bare minimum 24 hours this should have
happened a long time ago right and it
had to get to this place right
it's like insanity no like our account
was literally taken down for two months
and like
like we did nothing wrong but like
someone's out here publicly harassing
stalking being super abusive and like 24
hours is all we get
why do you think they do that do you
think they do that because people say oh
my gosh kanye's saying this on instagram
and they're getting you know clicks
that like they have a
terms and conditions and terror [ __ ]
that are [ __ ] but technically what
kanye's been doing up until this point
and that's exactly what trevor noah said
it's not illegal what he's doing so he
can't be arrested and it doesn't
necessarily violate their terms and
policies but calling someone a racial
slur does because they they policy
against hate speech i see
so it's like it's [ __ ] but it's
still [ __ ] because i mean i've
gotten in trouble for saying
oh my gosh i was trying to look for
molly
like
like i posted a picture and i said i was
looking for molly it was from five years
ago i was sitting in my cubicle when i
was working in finance and i got taken
off instagram for a few days what did
you do in finance
i like
like the bottom of the barrel roll i
always say i worked in finance right and
people are like oh my god but really i
just i worked for a team of financial
advisors
i hated it but that's impressive yeah i
mean i mean getting your foot in the
door was impressive i was trying to set
right i was trying to study for my
series seven but what's up
i have no idea
[Applause]
okay cool cool gotta give me a series i
just
seven
it totally does but
i'm really happy kanye was taken off me
too also it's been such a peaceful 24
hours right also
instagram has no right to
diagnose anyone
but it's you know it's widely known that
he struggles yeah and so i think it's
just the right thing to do i agree
and
i'd say this every day it's like it's
our job to come on here and report what
happened and obviously
every day for the last month there's
been some update with kanye and i know
people are tired of hearing it and i'm
tired of reporting on it but i just feel
like there's so many people consuming
this and like living for it like oh my
god the gossip and it's not like it's
really sad and like have you applied
this situation
to people who are not kim and kanye who
don't have millions of dollars they
don't have security like it's
heartbreaking like and i'm sure everyone
knows you know they either grew up in a
home that went through something similar
they have a friend who's like it's not
[ __ ] funny and it's really annoying
like honestly ben keeps asking me to
watch part two and part three of the
connie documentary and we watch the
first part and i thought it was amazing
but i'm just so annoyed like i i'm so
annoyed with kanye like i just wanted to
break yes and and i actually talked
about this on on my podcast as well
it's [ __ ] up what connie's doing at
the same time we know he's struggling so
it's hard to i know he's totally angry
at him but what he's doing to kim
people find it just kind of funny and oh
my god and it doesn't really affect her
she's rich it's abuse
no matter how much money you have it's
actually crazy to see you and this is
exactly what trevor noah said you could
be the most powerful woman in the world
kim kardashian is the most famous woman
in the world and even she's not
we're all equal like she's
going through this like a million other
people do yes and how terrifying that
someone who you had kids with and very
personal intimate life with knows
everything knows everything and at any
moment will say something that could
hurt you or your family it's every
woman's worst nightmare it is it really
really is so i'm just like so over kanye
and like i need him to just get him
himself together
and
i forget who said this but i read it
somewhere it's like you know struggling
with mental health is no excuse for this
yeah because it's abuse no
a
it
is
i saw trevor noah
like
four months ago okay oh wait it's so hot
okay that's so funny me and jackie have
a trevor know a story too we saw him at
brunch once and it was like a buffet
brunch at so house and we were like
obviously like dying and then he got up
to go to the like buffet and we were
just shook at the size of his tushy like
he has like he has like a like a really
good like like juicy ass like i'll never
forget like that's my fun fact about
trevor noah like he's always sitting at
the desk at the daily show so you don't
see his tuklas but it's still
actually like really juicy
that is [ __ ] amazing do you like do
you know kelly yes do people tell you
you look like her wait did we have this
conversation i'm in the twilight zone
i'm the queen of repeating things me too
i think we maybe have this no
someone else told me that
oh my god you were on druma green room
and she said the same thing you do who
do people tell you you look like um
jessica alba oh you do but but i do have
one of those faces where i think people
think i look like everyone i will have
people say oh i know you from somewhere
and i've never met them in my entire
life chameleon i just look like i look
like everyone yeah but you actually
really do look like mickey kelly which
is such a compliment because she is like
the most she's stuck that's the nicest
thing anyone has ever told me yeah i
could totally look like snooki so like
we're just like not
no you do not no i know i don't but
we're just like people really tell me i
look like um ricky lake who's 65 years
old i don't know who that is right um
beanie feldstein and snooki and i'm
sitting here with minky kelly slash
jessica alba and it just it's right it
ain't right please understand i've also
been told i look like steve buscemi
what which i kind of do in this weird
way claudia i'm not kidding
like the eyes like the bat like there's
something steve buscemi ish there
i've been told i look like people that
are you know that might be the funniest
thing you've ever said you do not look
like steve buscemi you do look like
jessica don't let don't be a steve be a
jessica okay i will actually be a sophia
no be a
[Laughter]
um phofia gonna keep going with the
stories and the rest of the show is
brought to you by jenny kane i know you
love jenny kane we talked about that
last time we were here the sweaters but
today we're talking about jenny kane
home perfect for your new apartment
jenny kane home creates california
inspired classics for any room or mood
grounded in natural textures and
inviting neutrals they are the pieces
you'll love coming home to so their
pacific bed which comes in linen and
bounce has the perfect
bounce you want it to be elevated yet
enduring and able to evolve with any
design choice and that's where the
pacific bed comes in with classic colors
like ivory and charcoal and timeless
fabrics that work with any bedroom style
the pacific bed is a piece you'll have
for years to come it's available in
natural linen ivory linen charcoal and
the ivory wool bounce check out jenny
kane home you love her sweaters and now
you got to check out her bed it's really
everything in the store because
everything jenny touches is just like
stunning and rich
um okay moving on let's let's back out
of the kardashians but kim was just on
ellen and ellen is entering like her
final era of television dumb after like
torturing us for so many years i didn't
even know she was on television still
well you know she was like cancelled for
being orders of course and then she came
back and like addressed it a little bit
but now i think she's just like hoping
we all forget
and we haven't forgotten but she is
ending her show and she's giving her
staff quote millions of dollars in
bonuses as the show ends stop
money
literally ellen is handing out quote
millions of dollars in bonuses to her
staffers the post can exclusively reveal
the final episode of the ellen generous
show is set to air may 26 with a source
telling the post on wednesday that ellen
and the production company warner
brothers worked together to make sure
every person was taken care of the exact
seven-figure sum that will be
distributed to the staffers was not
disclosed but the source declared it was
not even
you imagine
your boss making you cry go home and cry
every single day for two years and then
being like here's a few thousand bucks
well imagine if she well she says
millions of dollars in bonuses which
probably means how many people you think
work for her and oh [ __ ] like maybe 50
to 100 you think that's
fair fair camera guys producers right
i mean i would take the money but no
obviously i would take the money and
write a tell-all book but i'm sure the
money the money comes with some sort of
nda honestly
oh i hate to be so negative because i do
want to believe ellen's a good person
like she has changed millions of lives
on that show but
it's easy to be nice to everyone when
you're on tv it's when the cameras are
off are you nice to people no i think
you know what when there
are a certain amount of people that come
out and say you can't just you can't
deny it you're dead roll over right yeah
oh my gosh
this is the craziest thing i was
shopping for a couch right this was
yesterday i saw your instagram story i
actually did like that white couch okay
you did okay it's very trendy right now
thank you and it's gonna be so ugly next
year and i'm gonna throw away four
thousand dollars but we go and white is
tough and we go with the trends though
right now i deserve trendy you're trendy
i was living in my mom's basement for
two years let me get the four thousand
dollar couch please i think that's fair
so i'm looking for um
uh another couch
and
i see ellen degeneres
furniture yeah no it's not better than
jenny kane home no it's not yes i um
actually when i was in college i went to
bed bath and beyond like my day of
move-in to go to um to get like all the
stuff from my dorm and i was looking at
this bed spread and it said e.d by ellen
degeneres i'm like excuse me dysfunction
it makes her so rich it's like huge for
her know what she is too yeah ed by
ellen why okay well first of all i've
never heard of it second of all
i was so turned off by seeing her name
yeah that i didn't even look at what
type of couch she had to offer but do
know like while we hate her there are
like millions of women like who die for
her who've been watching her for years
who don't who don't care like that's why
she's so rich they watch her show
religiously they buy everything she does
they watch all of her ellen tubes all
those little kids that she like puts on
contract yeah like they're obsessed to
die for with her yes yes and they watch
they watch her every day
i get that so i mean it's kind of crazy
that ellen is leaving tv because she's
been on tv for as long as like i've been
watching tv but i'm just like over her
but what i really do like about ellen
well not ellen her show is that the
kardashians not to bring everything back
to the kardashians the kardashians like
love and trust her and anytime they have
like a big interview they always go on
ellen and she does a good job i have to
give credit she does a good job
interviewing them and she all these
celebrities love her so like she gets
amazing guests even though there's like
a million talk show hosts who
celebrities are friends with ellen has
this power over people everyone goes on
her show presidents like it's crazy
she's she is extremely talented as an
interviewer in in a bunch of ways and
you know what i say i don't like her i
don't like to say that until i know the
full scope and the full story it but it
does look really bad but you know what
i'd like to think that her you know
people coming forward about the toxic
workplace i like to think she heard that
and change you know let's give you all
the benefits yes
hopefully yes i love that approach okay
we're changing course just a little bit
because have you been keeping up with
the jesse smullet
saga no i haven't i mean i know
what happened but i have not been
keeping up so you know last week he was
sentenced to jail five months in jail
and like a couple hundred thousand
dollars in fines no yeah and he was like
in the courtroom screaming like i'm not
suicidal if anything happens to me i'm
not suicidal it was crazy and hit me
like taken out of the courtroom yeah and
then his brother posted something
basically saying he's been uh put in
what's it called when you're alone in
prison isolated isolated yes
yeah isolation cabin um cabin do you
ever watch parent trap no i still no i
see that
yes i remember solitude solitary
confinement oh my god there it is so and
like it was like this crazy thing but
now jesse smell it walks out of jail
after the appeal court orders a release
so basically
as far as you know let me just read it
because i
want to make sure i like fully
understand it but he is officially out
of jail following the decision earlier
today the illinois appeal court cut
short the former empire star's sentence
um and he walked out of cook county jail
at around 8 p.m local time he was
surrounded by members of his defense
team family and other supporters um
and his defense attorney told the media
that his client only drank water over
the past six months and ate no food
whatsoever that's interesting um and
what i had read was basically like he
filed for an appeal and these days like
the appeals court takes so long
by the time they would be able to get
him an appeal he would already be out of
jail because it was only a five-month
sentence okay so they just let him out
because he was a non-violent offender
and he didn't like you know hurt anyone
or kill anyone he just like wasted his
time and lied right which is a crime but
it's not a violent crime so he's out of
prison and he spent like six days in
prison
why okay why is his defense attorney
saying the water and is are they trying
to do like a mental insanity case you
know i what it sounded like to me was
that he was
clearly when he was in the courtroom
last week and they told him he was going
to jail he's like i'm not suicidal he
seems kind of paranoid that something
might happen to him so maybe he didn't
eat anything he didn't want to be
poisoned okay or maybe i'm watching like
too much orange is a new black but yeah
but that's what you do like to act a
little fbi
but that's what i don't know why she
shared the statement about water no i
don't know either that's very
interesting i would love to ask her
about it but
is he ever getting an acting role ever
again i don't i think he will me too
because you know i was looking for show
for articles to talk about this morning
and page six it was like jesse smelled
who's best known for his role on empire
it's like um actually he's best known
for lying to the police and making up a
hate crime
actually like not actually 100 well his
sister journey smell it is like pretty
up and coming she's pretty popular okay
um i don't know i mean the thing is it
happened so long ago that really even
though it was so crazy and so [ __ ] up
like it just seems like less of a big
deal now that it was like
i remember when it was happening people
were outraged like even you know a
really famous successful guy it could
happen to anyone and then like when he
that we found out he was lying it was
like he took advantage of us like
everyone was like but now it's been like
a couple years it was like was it so bad
right right time heals all wounds people
even though like it was a terrible thing
to do it was really
like made light of the whole thing and
people who doubt victims now are gonna
doubt because of jesse like what he did
was horrible but
it was horrible i do think that because
of what he did he almost might get a
role you think i i think well he's more
famous now it might be like sharknado
like one of those types of not a role
anyone really wants to take kind of yeah
but he has some notoriety now that's
true and i think that he will get a role
in something watched i do agree that
it'll be very interesting to watch um
what happens to his career like if he
continues to work yeah
um that was such a crazy thing it was
such a crazy time in america like it was
just chaotic i'm just remembering like
what speaking of prison like total
random segue but people always ask me
like what my final meal would be like if
i ever went to prison like what would
your final meal be
that's such a good question my favorite
food in the entire world is sushi
however
i have been to jail
oh my god so i'm so sorry i forgot you
have like a mug shot and everything
let's talk sorry let's just backtrack
really quickly can you tell me about the
day you were arrested so i've been
arrested multiple times oh really yes um
one of them i was actually there's the
drunk tank and then there's being booked
into jail and drunk tank is like when
you're just acting a fool and they wait
for you to sober up and they like
basically okay basically
one of my arrests i was actually booked
into the jail so orange jumpsuit they
took all of my belongings i had
extensions in my hair
they asked me if it was my hair and i
was like [ __ ] yes it is i paid for it
did they take it out they took it out
on they were clippings oh okay
i was disgusting back then blonde hair
clippings falling out of my head
all day
just whatever yeah um on my police
report at the top it says has like a
star and it says we because they
confiscate everything and i said have
her clip in extensions at the very top
it's incredible
but um i was booked into the jail and i
asked
underage public intoxication underage
drinking
resisting arrest in utah
yes okay thank you for sharing by the
way yeah but yes 100 i do have a mug
shot i've seen it on some of your merch
i have two
which one do you like better um not the
one that is publicized
well that's just how the world works
honestly right
um and what was jail like
so
uh it was very interesting i actually
made really good friends in there i had
no idea how long i was gonna be in there
for i think they were trying to [ __ ]
with me a little bit and kind of trying
to scare me straight and they were like
you could be in here for up to a week
right you could be on that show a any
scared straight yes and but the thing is
is there were there were women in there
for
really crazy right you know like murder
and stuff right but anyways my jail cell
um
the i shared a bunk
top or bottom i was on the bottom she
was already at the top
she did not say hi to me um
i was young that was my first time ever
there i was terrified and so i decided
to reach out to her although a sweet
lady did tell me before i got in there
to not talk to anyone not tell anyone
what i did like real [ __ ]
i didn't listen i didn't listen
and i remember asking the girl in the
top bunk i said i'm just really really
scared do you have any advice for me
because you know it seems like you've
been here for a while you're very
relaxed up there
and i'll never forget these words she
said
it's scarier out there than it is in
here wow so it's chilling that's chilly
i'm like i i don't know what you've been
up to she crawled down but the whole
point my whole point is the jail food no
wait sorry i have more questions before
you're like shut the [ __ ] up so how many
evenings did you spend in the facility i
was only there i think for
maybe
48 hours which is a long time oh my god
it's an eternity in eternity
you can't i don't have people's phone
numbers memorized i can't call and you
were was your family wondering where you
were did they know oh they went to the
jail my grandpa walked in was freaking
out let her out like all she did was you
know really drunk
but um
the my my cellmate
came down so oh whoops okay they gave us
um
food jail food in the cell are you made
in like a cafeteria
they shove it underneath the door
and i took a bite
and i literally spit it out into my
napkin and i was repulsed
oh my i think it was like
some
macaroni but it was it wasn't [ __ ]
macaroni and then a roll that was just
not a [ __ ] role and then like
meatloaf that was not [ __ ] me right
right it was it was horrifying oh my god
and
i
um
my cellmate
comes down from the bottom bunk this is
the first time she's come down
and she asked if she could have my plate
of food that was the only thing she
really said to me besides the other
thing
and i said sure
and she took the train she went back up
to her bunk and that was it she was
really scary um i was really scared to
be in there i was like what is she going
to do to me but anyways the food is
actually really really really [ __ ]
bad so
oh back to jesse small yeah with my
experience
um i wouldn't go for sushi i would oh my
god i would have to go i think steak i
forgot the original question i've been
so wrapped up in storytelling well you
know what do you remember alexis nyers
pretty wild bling ring yes yes so she
came on the show and she basically she
struggled with addiction and at the
height of her addiction is when she got
arrested and she said she spent the
first couple nights in jail going
through withdrawal because obviously she
didn't have any drugs in jail and the
way she like the picture she painted she
said literally the first night in prison
like
the picture she painted like i was just
it was horrifying it's the scariest
[ __ ] thing in the entire world i
didn't know when i would get out right
they give you like little recess breaks
and besides that you're in a tiny little
cell um and all you have access to are
like some [ __ ] books right how old
were you
that time well you were underage
drinking right yes so i want to say i
was
18 19. that's so young
very young
um
it was like it was the most traumatic
thing and i i couldn't talk to the
outside world the only person i could
talk to was like a bail bondsman and i
was crying to him and he was very nice
and he like calmed me down i did make
friends in there though i did you she'll
talk to them
no i didn't get their phone numbers i
think all of us were a little bit
distraught were they your age there was
one girl that i
just
was it was like a magnetic field that i
went to her she was my age she didn't
look like she had maybe murdered someone
you know
um
but they they were nice in there okay
you know there's definitely like clicks
like they perform clicks in there right
and i'm like sitting there i'm like [ __ ]
i don't know what click i belong in i
don't know how long i'm gonna be in here
today's two questions did you go to
college yes and was applying to college
like a journey was that on your record
no but it's it's [ __ ] with other
things that i tried to get right like
apartments
not
um actually yes because every time i get
a background check but it does show up
and it's it's so minor it's not a felony
i did get a felony but it was taken off
okay
for forgery
which sounds really really bad right
i was on the cover of
busted newspaper which was a utah
newspaper for anyone who got arrested
that week it was every 7
every gas station all around utah i was
the front cover it said i got arrested
for forgery because i had used a fake id
oh the drama the draw and people were
like were you foraging chad right and
you want to work in finance right right
and so it was just really messed up but
it's utah there's no crime and so
they're just going afterward you know so
it has like it's followed you in your
life quite a bit
and not
not it hasn't been detrimental but i
mean do you know what global entry is oh
you're not eligible
i applied and they denied me and i
appealed it and they denied me again
i wrote like a three-page essay as to
why i shouldn't be held like
i shouldn't be getting in trouble for
stuff i did like eight years ago
they don't care they don't want me on it
they don't want me traveling globally
that easily well can i tell you
something i'm not a global entry member
um and at certain airports and that's
why i always fly internationally into
jfk they have this thing called mobile
passport
it's an app that you download that
nobody knows about and i don't even wish
i was not blowing it up on the spot
right now the line is shorter than
global entry and you get through my
friend brian he's like a traveler he has
global entry when we travel
internationally i have my mobile
passport we get through in the same
exact amount of time no way yep it's
like as you're on the plane you you're
like three hours before you land to fill
out the information on mobile entry and
you just go right through
okay my life has completely changed
don't feel bad about it i don't have
global injury either and i'm like a big
traveler and it's just because i'm too
lazy to go to brooklyn to do the
appointment oh i tried to get global
entry for over a year that's how like
dedicated i was that is so interesting
thank you for sharing all that i really
appreciate it do you still like feel
triggered by it like you have dreams
about you oh my god no no no no i was
out of control i probably deserve to
like go in there honestly i feel like
it's a lot of people like personally my
worst nightmare like when i have crazy
nightmares it's about going to jail it's
like something i'm most afraid of really
yeah and i think that's common for a lot
of people being convicted wrongly of
something is just being it's not even
about the trial it's not about the crime
it's just being in prison
so you've kind of faced head on what i
think a lot of people are like yeah in
their lives most afraid of you're like a
[ __ ] scary ass [ __ ] it made me the
woman i am today uh hi my my i'm wearing
the hoodie oh yeah is that your merch
yes where can people get it they can get
it at sophiafranklin.com the the merge
says our attorney will get us out of
everything
because
i'm 18 years old i do not have an
attorney my family does not have that
type of money where i should be saying
anything remotely near that
and when the police were arresting me
uh i told my friend to
shut the [ __ ] up that our attorney would
get us out of everything
it's like something you probably saw on
tv literally on tv literally probably
thought it made me sound rich and cool
and it's so cringy and it's in my police
report the cop actually wrote it down
that is so cringy i'm dying well now
iconing off of it iconic it is no you
know what you are now in the perfect
business because first of all your life
as someone who's been to prison endless
episodes
and nobody cares if you have a record
when you're a podcaster no one i'm i'm
in the right business
how did you get the job in finance
um that was actually tricky it was an
issue and i did have to write and
explain but also finance i mean they let
some [ __ ] slide no i mean everyone in
finance goes to jail yeah
you just skipped a step
okay we've got one more story with
sophia and it's brought to you by
bowling branch they make the softest
organic sheets on the market and they
get better with every wash and comfort
isn't their only standard they use 100
sustainable raw materials and as the
first fair trade certified manufacturer
of linen you can feel as good about your
bowl and brand sheets as they feel
against your skin
so bowling branch sheets are on my bed
they're on my pillows i have their throw
blankets i literally have everything
from them they're the best brand on the
planet i'm a bowling branch ride or die
i actually found out about bowling
branch before they were a sponsor from
rach parcell because they're good enough
for rach parcells big-ass utah mansion
then they're good enough for my little
apartment so i have the signature hem
sheets from bowlin branch it's their
best seller they're buttery soft
lightweight organic cotton and a classic
satin weave for sheets that get softer
over time it's not too cool and it's not
too hot it's the perfect year-round
sheets for most sleepers bowling branch
focuses on quality over quantity so they
don't have an inflated thread count
because more isn't always better
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt at bowlingbranch.com get 15 off
your first set of sheets when you use
promo code toast at checkout that's
bowlin branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch
promo code toast
now our final story is some
disappointing news to people who don't
want to pay for netflix because this
might be the end of sharing netflix
passwords no netflix knows you share
your password and soon you might have to
start paying for the privilege over the
last year netflix has been working on a
way to enable members who share outside
their household to do so easily and
securely while also paying a bit more i
like how they're making it seem like
they're helping us like you're going to
do it more securely who cares who cares
as a part of that effort over the next
two weeks netflix will roll out two test
features in chile costa rica and peru
called extra member and profile transfer
with extra member people who subscribe
to netflix standard and premium plans
can pay to add an account for up to two
people they don't live with those extra
members will have access just like any
other netflix account including their
own profile and login but at a
discounted rate so you're still paying a
membership they don't understand we
don't need it to be all fancy like
people are using [ __ ] netflix
passwords from people they dated 10
years ago and it's like no one's getting
hurt no one is getting hurt they're
using that as a cover-up no they're just
they just raised their prices and then
they made these like family plans like
me and my family we all have different
profiles we're paying more like leave us
alone leave us alone don't have enough
money
i was just gonna say that i'm all about
being greedy but netflix has enough
money they've made enough questionable
movies they paid literally adam sandler
300 million dollars for like a couple
movies like they obviously have
indispensable wealth like [ __ ] off leave
us alone leave us alone it ain't right
oh my gosh do you think it's they're
going to really enforce it well they're
going to test it they are like netflix
when you're that big no one's going to
cancel their netflix over this because
people can't live without netflix
right we can't we can't do anything
about it do you pay for your own netflix
i don't pay for any streaming service i
have everyone's password whose networks
do you use in my family like we all take
on different things like i don't pay for
netflix i don't pay for hulu but i do i
think i pay for the hbo max
i
have
there are some passwords that i
logins that i don't even know who they
are but mostly ex-boyfriends maybe maybe
a couple from my mom mm-hmm spotify is
my mom but the rest are just dudes it's
like so annoying like now we're paying
for so many subscriptions i still have
cable are you a cable girly yes which
cable do you have in new york um i got
verizon that's a good one is that the
better way to go than spectrum so i have
like a really warm place in my heart for
spectrum it's like what i grew up with
that doesn't mean it's the best but it's
like the interface i'm most comfortable
with and it reminds me of home i just
like love it and i switched out of it
and i felt this like gaping hole in my
heart for spectrum
wow
but if you are not a loser like me
i'm like whoa whoa that's some
attachment verizon's like the fastest
it's the best one okay see neither of
those exist in utah so i had to what did
you have in utah
what xfinity and then what is the other
one there's another one
i don't know dish
with the satellite xfinity is actually
really good i like it it is yeah well i
think verizon's the best me too they
don't have xfinity here oh it's like a
regional thing i think they have it in
boston but they don't have it here got
it got it what did they do i don't know
anyone who does i cannot believe you
were that attached to
i have issues but no but actually yeah
no i love spectrum it's just like this
random thing that like brings me comfort
like it just reminds me of like growing
up with my sisters i know it's like
really weird no that's so interesting
i'm trying to think if there's some
random like attack you're gonna have to
something were you the type of kid who
like brought their own teddy bear
blankets to sleepovers no no i just
found out my husband podcast with me on
tuesday that he was
and he was that kid and he grew up in
the city and he left his bear in a cab
after a sleepover and it was like the
worst day of his life it was he also the
kid that in the middle of the night
would ask for his parents to pick him up
that's literally what i asked him yes
and here's the real kicker he was a kid
in the middle of the night well he was a
kid who went to sleepovers brought his
own teddy bear and also brought his own
fan
no yeah no
no black fan yeah he brought it with him
everywhere he's done like a face fan no
like a sliding fan yeah
yeah claudia no no no no no i swear to
god to plug into the wall yeah
that it's the cutest thing i've ever
heard but like the crazy and also just
know like when my husband was younger he
was like obese so like that's why he was
probably really hot
he'll admit it to you he needed the fan
wait how is it recording with him oh my
god you do it a lot no well i do it like
jackie does it and i do it he always
fills in for one of us and it's like we
have a very interesting dynamic and like
we're very we bicker
um and then when you put that on a
podcast people feel weird and they tell
you your marriage is like trash and for
me like i get so much [ __ ] for
everything but like when people start um
people tell you your marriage is trash
like like i'm so mean to ben like you
guys have a [ __ ] up dynamic oh i mean
of course when i that's like one thing i
can't take heat on like i could really i
give gotten [ __ ] backlash you're
sensitive about that i'm so so i try and
honestly avoid we were gonna do a
podcast together because like it's so
fun um but the critiques about my
marriage like are so tough for me
um so he was on on tuesday and like i
was like literally acting like a
different person like
i'm just and it's not it's just who i am
i'm like critical and like i joke i poke
fun and so is ben and like we're used to
that dynamic but if you're new to you're
just listening like you i guess you
could be like claudia's a [ __ ] so i was
just being protective of him almost yeah
on tuesday like i was literally you
should read the comments on this youtube
like people were like who is this person
like you're like honey bear like you're
so sweet
like and that's just not how i am like
i'm [ __ ] i'm like this new york jew
i'm very to the point i'm tough
and it rubs people the wrong way so i
honestly like i would love to podcast
with him more but i have like trauma
well
i also have trauma because of all that
[ __ ] that happened and i'm really
curious in my next relationship if i
even want to make it public or not right
no i know we spoke about that last time
a little bit like it's definitely
something that scarred you yes right and
i i don't know it's hard because it's
you it's your life and so you want to
share but you also need to protect
certain things in your life yeah so i
mean what do you think well i think it
depends are you dating a celebrity are
you dating a private person i mean if
i'm dating a celebrity that's going
everywhere and it's elevating my
celebrity right like how private is this
person it depends on the person also
they might have uh something to say like
no i don't want to be on it you know
yeah i think that they would be totally
down to be on it they're not a celebrity
at all are you talking about a specific
person in your life right now um just a
teeny tiny bit oh okay so there is an
actual person i thought we were being
hypothetical there's
we are being hypothetical because it's
way too early and it takes me months and
months and months to even be like i'm
yeah entertaining this honestly after
what you'd been through like i wouldn't
be shocked and i wouldn't blame you for
keeping that [ __ ] private
i i think so too and i think i would be
the same way as you there's certain
relationships that are it's protected
yes it's too much and you'll never
regret being private about it but you
will regret being public about it yeah
that's my stage advice and i mean i i
think i've heard stories from people
saying being public about it can ruin a
relationship no and like i know of
youtubers who have like you know blown
up their partners and then their
partners get divorced and they're like
now they have a platform to talk [ __ ]
about you when you gave them that
[ __ ] platform right so honestly
i'd say no okay i like that answer and i
like you and i love you for being here
thank you so much and thanks for sharing
all that jail stuff that was super
interesting um everyone sophie has a
podcast it's called sofia with an f she
drops episodes every week it's so great
you have tons of guests she's in new
york now she's going to be on the toast
as much as we need her to be literally
and yeah the merch is sophiafranklin.com
your instagram is just sophia franklin
sophia with an s franklin with a y you
just said sophia's an s oh [ __ ] sophia
with an f franklin with a y sofia
yanklin and
and i love you thank you for being here
thank you anything else you want to
promote um you know what i just found
out what my tick tock handle was
yesterday and i still don't know what it
is it's sophia franklin zero yeah did
you follow me back on tick-tock because
i'm always seeing your tic-tock oh my
god i don't know if i'm not i mean
i think i do i think you should like but
i do a lot of time and effort into my
ticket i do have someone to help me with
my tick tock okay so you have to forgive
me but this was amazing how you're like
the best i really really want to come
back
your tick tock is playing i'm on tick
tock right now because i'm so bored just
kidding i really want to um do it with
jackie i know i know she'll probably be
like back in the podcasting space in
like one or two months but let's give
her i don't know maybe more might be
less no we're not we're not we're
putting pressure on women no we don't do
that no thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast we're
back tomorrow with our final episode of
the week with josh peck and if you
haven't read his book we're gonna be
going really in depth i'm about to
finish it it's so good so pick it up on
amazon thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning to us the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the fastback stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast and where
podcasts can be found like spotify
institute public radio i have radio cast
box all the places so wherever you live
in a podcast find us this morning just
leave a five-star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are have
an amazing day you guys will see you
tomorrow for friday's episode bye
you